hi I'm Andre kuznia Eric and I'm the
director of document and media systems
for Wolfram research I am presenting
what's new in CDF I do this every year
to fill everybody in on all the things
that are happening with our CDF related
projects I'm involved with a number of
different groups that work on notebook
specific things and other kinds of
projects related to authoring and
content creation particularly relating
to our documentation and other big
projects like that one of the projects
I'm responsible for is essentially
product managing CDF every year I give a
review of how things are going with
things related to CDF so let me just
jump right into that right now
we've got the new Wolfram player for iOS
which John has written this awesome blog
post about and for us it's a pretty big
deal let's see if I can get to that I
hope it shows up you know my whole
internet thing is kind of not happening
but let me just keep going so we've been
working on this for quite a long time
and I'll go into a few more details
about it but it's big deal it gives us
our our third a leg of our deployment
concept being able to put content into
our notebook technology across all
relevant platforms so that's you know
your computer on the desktop on the web
through the cloud and in mobile devices
in this case through iOS CDF player is
always following our product releases so
when 11:2 came out we had CDF player
follow in two to three weeks that's the
kind of schedule we believe we can
consistently maintain and that's because
a while back we did some retooling of
the way we build CDF player and
have it essentially almost the same
thing as Mathematica itself it doesn't
mean it has a fairly large footprint but
it gives you the efficiency and
confidence that everything that is in
Mathematica is in CDF there's some minor
updates to what's in Mathematica wool
from desktop and other products like
that that I'll make I'll show shortly
and bigger meta point as I have been
warning for the last couple years the
plugin is no longer installed or
supported by our products and that's
because this year started off with all
the web browsers abandoning plugins so
while that was a really useful feature
of what our player technology offered
and you know was very handy for
publishers and others I mean we have
quite a few partnerships of publishers
that relied on that plugin but you know
it's the end of its lifecycle it's the
way it goes so at this point you have to
be working with the cloud to put things
on the web let's talk a little bit more
about iOS so we're talking about iPads
and iPhones which is why as a case with
John's blog post you can have notebooks
in your packet Rob and Jason gave talks
yesterday so if any of you were
interested in those I hope you caught
those but if not we are videotaping
everything that is presented at the
conference so or video recording I
should say and you'll find that stuff
online soon after the event some quick
points about how this works you know the
player it's it's a free app and it's the
use of it is totally free for viewing
notebooks and CDF files but that's
static viewing if you want to interact
with it I should make clear it's perhaps
a little confusing but I think clear it
only operates at the level of free CDF
and that just means that it's a
completely sandbox device so those of
you familiar with what goes on with the
two levels of CDF that we have you know
the kind of Enter
prai's cdf features that involve loading
data from files or connecting to other
systems is it's that's not going to
happen on a mobile device that's fully
secured like the Apple devices are but
you can still you know interact with CDF
documents that are completely
self-contained with everything that gets
evaluated and computed in that
particular file and you can do that with
your cloud account login it's not that
you're necessarily connecting to the
cloud to use the cloud you're simply
you're being verified or authenticated
through our cloud to use the app for
free or you could interact with files
that have been saved from an enterprise
product so any of you developers here
who are enterprise users and you want to
put CDF files out to people who don't
have any of our technology you can just
point them to the mobile app and they
can interact with the CDF files you give
them
five
we've got the in-app purchase it's it's
a one-time purchase all it does is flip
a switch and says you're your player is
now an interactive player John do you
recall is that the ten bucks 15 bucks
you remember we priced $10 so but one of
the really cool features and you know
the benefit of having the cloud login is
that if you've got files on your cloud
account the player can browse those
files and then run those locally on the
player pulling them off of the cloud so
that's a nice detail just a reminder
about the CDF player itself the start up
screen and pardon me I'm gonna try
another connection and see if I get
lucky on VPN start up screen had been
redesigned since version 11 first came
out which includes a cleaner
presentation of this information or icon
I should put it of activating CDF player
as Player pro so player pro goes back a
number of years you know if you know if
Enterprise isn't really going to be a
workable solution for you an alternative
is for your users to purchase an upgrade
to CDF player and they can get the
similar features as Enterprise through
it directly and you know we also had
this show at startup check box it's kind
of nice when you're deploying CDF files
as applications you don't want people to
see this startup screen necessarily and
they won't if they're starting files
directly by double-clicking or
drag-and-drop but if they are starting
in the player they can also choose to
make it go away now all right so then in
mathematica will from desktop will from
one we we no longer have a CDF export
item in the file menu we now rely simply
on save as
do the right thing when you choose CDF
and we define the right thing to be save
your CDF at the license level that your
product is so if you've got an
enterprise version of Mathematica save
as CDF is gonna give you an enterprise
CDF if you don't you'll get free CDF it
seems pretty straightforward if you're
on enterprise and you really still want
to put out free CDF to somebody you can
use the deploy CDF command function now
exporting CDF does still exist it's just
it's part of a workflow that is related
to the preview step so we've left the
preview menu item and the whole point of
that is your working file you're in
Mathematica you want to see what your
user of that file is going to see when
they're with the player and so you go to
preview it shows you the toolbar banner
that the CDF player puts up and includes
this additional yellow banner that you
see here which just indicates what
license level you're at and has the
export button to just save out your file
from there okay so no more plugin this
is a part where I really wanted to show
you guys stuff on our network and I just
kind of can't so I think I'm gonna wave
my hands a lot and have you follow up
looking at this file in the archive that
we provide after the conference these
links will be I'll be updating this file
to have these point to public served
files these are all emerging features
but what I was gonna get at is and let's
see yeah I still like I just don't have
any any servers here which is a little
bit
annoying yeah I don't know I came from
the the room the setup room and I was on
VPN everything was good I walk in here
and everything's no good yeah okay
this one and let's see what happens here
I mean
what the heck this was all just good
I want
I don't think so I wouldn't have
configured that
I mean restart Firefox see if that helps
me
it's not helping me
I don't know but this we were inspecting
this I don't think we edited any of this
stuff oh here
so yeah I don't know do you think
there's anything you want to look at
there is it just because VPN keeps
trying to run should I let me go with
that I had sewed it in and I say that
you know it's weird let me see if I can
quit it
to quit I can tell
up there goes all right let's see if
with it's not running
I can at least
you can try it again announced here
right here
that's what spirited that partly
initially
and so I should turn this off right
there we go it's better than nothing all
right so just to see if I can show a
little bit of something here on our CDF
website one of the main issues we have
to deal with and we'll be doing this
throughout our website our instances of
CDF's embedded into our web pages and
what I was trying to happily show and I
can't really but I can probably show it
as soon as I walk out this room and any
of you could look me up afterwards if
you really want to see this in action
what you see here as the CDF and you
know any of these exist not any of them
but most of these examples we have
working running through the clouds so
that when you get to a page like this
you see a static image momentarily and
then it refreshes itself into an
interactive you know elements an
interactive manipulate object on the
screen no plugins no downloads nothing
like that required it's all being served
off of our cloud off of our servers on
the web for the web so we're trying to
make that happen here the same thing for
demonstrations at Stephens keynote you
will have seen the the rescanning of our
demonstration site you can see here it's
complaining about Flash plugin that you
know all plugins are gone now so it's
not like it's just us but any of these
examples here we're also running flash
movies as previews and we've we've got
replacements coming in that are based on
gif animations so this is all part of
what I was hoping to show we've we've
determined that of all the eleven
thousand demonstrations we have so far
that are you know submitted by people
all around the world about 85% of them
are working in the cloud at least
rendering you know at least coming up
and appearing like they should do what
they need to do but more testings
required for a lot of them they some are
too slow for practical use when we were
first starting cloud development it was
a real problem that when you're trying
to interact directly you're moving a
slide or a control or whatever you know
there's always going to be some amount
of lag you're dealing with sending you
know signals across great distances but
we are pretty confident that experience
can get really tightened up to the
degree that it's still reasonable to to
run most of these things but it requires
optimization and if you're putting you
know your own manipulates or other kind
of interactive objects online you've got
to do a little bit of your own testing
just confirm you know put things into
your cloud account deploy it from your
cloud account I have a look and see how
it plays
there are optimizations that that may be
required and there's a bit of work ahead
of us to make that happen but it is an
ongoing project right now for us to
deliver all of these things directly
through the cloud as much as possible
for those instances where it's not
practical it'll be like it is now where
there's a big download button and you
just download it to your desktop and run
from there and and we are improving the
download experience as well I mean I
think I haven't quite seen it yet for
what we're doing with our demonstration
site but when you're working with our
cloud and you're downloading notebooks
from the cloud they'll immediately open
in Mathematica or other desktop products
so it's a pretty smooth experience one
of the other things we're doing that I
I'm pretty happy about is in the case of
demonstrations but this this will be
true for anything that we would call a
CDF you know where we have the idea of
resource objects or you know
repositories that are full of data and
content and other kinds of things you
know we're we're gonna have a function
repository what does that mean anything
that you might code can be delivered as
and as a function and like an API almost
off of our web servers for anyone to
execute within their copy of Mathematica
and or anybody using the Wolfram
language and just like with our data
repository where you can pull data down
we can do that for anything and in this
case we're again using the demonstration
site as a great source for a bunch of
content and these are some examples so I
should be able to just evaluate if I got
any kind of a web connection here yes
thank you
and what I did there was pull this
manipulate right off of our servers and
you know I'm working with it within our
product now so it's a smooth and
interactive as it should be well that's
a pretty good experience if I we haven't
achieved this yet but if nothing else
like I was saying with that download
experience if if the cloud isn't giving
you the kind of connectivity or speed
that you want for an interactive on the
web we should at least be able to get
this into your player as efficiently and
cleanly as possible
whoops so you know any of these work
quickly and smoothly but it's not just
the interactive elements any in the case
of the demonstrations project you know
the demonstrations all come with
abstracts and information about who
posted them so you know we can pull all
that information separately and
similarly if you know our plans are to
expand this kind of idea with a CDF
repository in general or a notebook
repository so you know anything you
might put up and are prepared to put up
publicly can then be delivered through a
mechanism like this
well yeah I mean the demonstration site
right you know so if you go to the
demonstration site just like with the
data repository you know you would be
able to click and pull the thing right
out of there like paste you know copy
and paste this command would we create a
dedicated browser just for the
demonstrations repository
probably not but but for a CDF
repository we would you know just like
you know for the data repository and
what you'll see with the function
repository here's an example
but
so you're saying if there's a function
somebody wrote and put on our function
repository auto-completion could find
that that would be interesting
oh right in other words if you write it
out correctly to begin with yeah okay
fair enough
here's an example of just taking what's
in the repository and pulling it up as
an entire notebook so what I've just
done through the command line here is
similar to having to go to the website
and push the button that says download
the notebook you know the opal comes
down and then open the notebook so it's
it's convenient and efficient I think
it's quite nice so I think just to wrap
up here quickly we're talking about the
cloud and and what really makes the
cloud exciting is that you want to be
able to share anything you do with
anybody else and you want to be able to
do it easily and it's something where
we're going through a UX cycle right now
where we're updating that process to
make it as few clicks and as little
thinking as possible required to take
whatever notebook you have and share it
with somebody else and and from that
point that file is at least to the level
of what CDF offers interactive for
anybody who's you know you provide that
link to or you share it with if you're
publishing it it's the same difference
anybody in the world you know can
interact with that file but not
indefinitely they'll get a certain
number of interactions and then they
reach a threshold and they either have
to download it and continue with the
free player or save it to their own
cloud account and continue with it there
we think that's a fair way for you to
get your content out and have people
interact with it and kind of experience
what our technology offers but
without overburdening our you know
expense of running these servers to host
all this stuff particularly if you know
you have produced something that goes
viral you know that's our computation
dime that's running this thing
constantly for people so it's fair
enough that it switches over to their
requirement to take action and this is
that works for every individual file
going this so it's like if you produce
another different thing than the it's
that process starts over okay so you
know our website is constantly being
updated there's more information about
what I just described that's going to be
coming soon on the website to spell all
of those details out and like I said
follow up with me later if you want to
see a little bit more of the cloud
embedding which I unfortunately was not
able to demonstrate thanks
[Applause]